hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 4 video if
you haven't seen it just careful for
spoilers so here we go little pig little
pig let me know who Judas real father is
I cannot believe that they did that that
blew my mind that's usually something
that creators keep really close to the
vest and reveal it like conventions long
after the show has gone off the air
like ten years later someone's like so
tell us finally who is Judas real father
but they kind of turned it into this
metaphor for them accepting the negan
situation so let's just do top 10 WTF
and Easter eggs
it was a 90-minute episode so I think
the biggest surprise number 10 is that
they did not slaughter someone during
the episode like you kind of thought for
a little while that negan was gonna open
up on Olivia
then when Spencer got back they kind of
teased you that Rick might kill him just
to show you that he's not a total coward
now even though he is definitely a
little gun-shy like he gives him
Michonne Scott so number 9 giving him
Michonne's gun at the end you can see
like her heart breaks just a little bit
having to see Rick like this and she is
pissed as hell but they kind of tried to
get that across through the episodes so
you know number 8 most of the survivors
are pissed and still ready to double
down just letting you know that things
are [ __ ] right now but it is not the end
number seven was negan's entrance little
pig little pig let me in that was a
moment that was taken right out of the
comics as was the moment you know number
six with Carl kind of setting up where
his arc is they're speeding through it
really fast so I don't know how much of
Carl's story from the comics they're
gonna do but they've kind of already
given a lot of that to Daryl's character
so it makes me think that they're not
gonna do a whole lot of Carl negan stuff
from the comics but he basically stands
up to him you know get out of here
before you find out how dangerous we are
you can see just how young Carl is in
the comics when this is all happening
compared to how old he is on the TV show
he's way older on the TV show just
because the actors aging so much faster
but number five meet Laura she's another
character from the comics who she's the
one that kind of shouts out she has a
couple lines later in the episode when
they're grabbing all the guns she's
actually from much later in the comics
compared to where they are right now but
she is important for Dwight's character
so I'm guessing the
just speeding up a lot of at white comic
book story stuff but number four Timmy
in the dick brigade that was such a
great moment when they grabbed the RPG
the one that Darrell used to kill him
those guys are a bunch of [ __ ] and
it makes you so heartbroken when number
three Dwight takes his bike you can get
this all back all you got to do is say
the thing so that was also part of negan
steel when he was like maybe Daryl can
come back if he says the right thing he
was talking about getting Daryl to say
thee I'm negan thing which you know
Daryl flat out refuses to say so he's
not getting the bike back not coming
back to the safe zone anytime soon but
that look on his face is just priceless
it's just so heartbreaking cuz in one
moment you see like the sadness in their
eyes but like also Rick to like they
would zoom in on Rick's face while he
was holding Lucille there so you also
kind of think that he might make a move
and they found the bike the place they
found it is actually where Denise was
killed that's why Rosita shouts her out
when she was looking for the gun Anwar
Eugene bit Dwight in the nuts
they're basically rifling through like
all their keepsakes so a lot of them
like Enid's balloons had special
significance
making it that much sadder in the
balloons were actually from a Glenn
episode that was how they signaled the
safe zone and distracted the walkers to
get away so the reason she fought so
hard to keep the balloons was just to
remember clan but the whole point of the
episode was just to show you how negan
walked in and used the safe zone like a
target and Rick you know number two has
that big speech where he says negan's in
charge so there's a whole lot of stuff
happening here like Rick is rolling over
in a really heartbreaking way but they
use those moments of tension between the
characters this doesn't have to be our
life in like Rosita at the end of the
episode when she asks Eugene to make her
a bullet to show you that it's not the
end but my number one craziest moment
was actually a tie between negan's taunt
at the end of the episode which is also
right out of the comics totally
not-safe-for-work
I just lived my business down your
throat and you thank me for it that's
like literally right out of the comic
book in then the other Shane speech
where Rick remembers Shane and
acknowledges Judith as his daughter
so just completely blew my mind it had
been a joke in the fandom for a long
time to say haha yeah baby Judith
probably Shane's
but since they said it in an episode
it's almost Canon like the way Rick says
it he just believes that that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's totally true
but you can choose to take it how you
will so you can let me know do you
believe Rick when he says that Judith is
Shane's daughter and even as crazy as
that was in the whole episode it was
still fun to remember Shane every once
in a while whenever they get the
opportunity but just to reference the
smoking tiger in the room Rick says they
don't have enough manpower they
reference hilltop you know even with
them we don't have enough they don't
know about the kingdom in Ezekiel yet so
like next week we'll go to hilltop Jesus
actually knows a lot more about what's
going on with all the different factions
so hopefully he'll have some other
rallying cry for the survivors that want
to stand up to negan but I think that's
probably what they'll build up to for
the mid-season finale is that there'll
be like another big conflict with the
Savior's so if you haven't read the
comics there is like a big conflict
called all-out war but it's like way
further ahead in the comics like it's
not anywhere near what's happening right
now do you think that that's what
they're going to be doing this season
like they'll just blow through a whole
bunch of comic book plot and get there
faster because there's a whole bunch
more comic book stuff that they can do
on the TV show but it just depends on
how fast they move so if they actually
do end up doing stuff like that you know
when it happens in episodes I'll try to
point it out like when it happened in
the comics but you don't actually have
to read the comics to understand what's
going on they did a pretty good job of
leading you through the episode
especially with the way they tried to
tip you off with Rosita with the bullets
so it's like okay yeah they're very
clearly gonna stand up to negan
eventually but not right away
and speaking of hilltop for those of you
wondering about the Maggie fake-out know
she's not dead but they were originally
taking her to the doctor at Hilltop
because of the baby when they ran into
negan before episode 1 happened so when
they left her she just continued on
there so we'll probably pick back up
with her when we see hilltop in next
week's episode but the reason why they
told negan she was dead is just to throw
him off her scent remember he was like
oh you know I was thinking about making
a play for even though I just killed her
husband like he was definitely rubbing
Rick's nose in it all episode so it
gonna make the payoff the ultimate
payoff however long it takes to get
there that much more satisfying so next
week Jesus is back be sure to subscribe
to get that video I will do a trailer
video tomorrow and there is a new
Walking Dead giveaway that's going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it just a heads up it doesn't
look like there gonna be any breaks in
the episodes before the mid-season
finale that's episode 8 which is
currently scheduled for December 11th so
if there is a change to the schedule and
they go on break or something like that
I'll totally do a video about it but
that does sound about right that they
would have their mid-season finale
sometime earlier in December so I don't
think there's gonna be any issues with
that so walking dead trailer posting
tomorrow will you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for that Dave
Chappelle Walking Dead clip and you can
click here for my ghost in the shell'
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight